let's go back to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 we are going to take our next
caller from the four four three area
code caller please tell us who you are
where you're calling from and you can go
right into your question if you will I
David my name is Joey I'm calling from
Baltimore great I'm wondering about how
you see the political fallout of the DC
shooting playing out do you think a
shooting allow Republicans political
cover to further distract from
investigations into the Trump campaign
and Russian influence on the election
yeah I think it probably will
immediately you know when it happened I
was watching this statement from
President Donald Trump and immediately I
thought this is going to potentially
boost Trump's approval or at least
temper disapproval of Trump this is
going to take attention away from many
of the very serious things that are
happening and by the way even though it
should get us thinking once again about
an issue that has not been in the
forefront for a while which is gun
safety regulations it probably won't
really do anything to move forward gun
safety regulations despite the fact that
we had a member another member of
Congress remember Gabby Giffords some
years ago also shot another member of
Congress shot I absolutely and Pat I
said it to you when they were watching
that I have serious concerns about that
and you know we've seen the Trump Russia
scandal after scandal with Trump all
sorts of scandals his music Middle
Eastern trip and everything
what's going on with Trump's tax plan
nothing what's going on with the repeal
of the Affordable Care Act and its
replacement with that bogus version two
of Republic air or whatever nothing
what's going on with the Mexican wall
absolutely nothing travel ban dead again
earlier this week and we might see
another layer of that as a result of
this shooting although I don't know that
it's going to stay in the news cycle
that long well especially if Republicans
are able to play the victim here I mean
obviously these assassination attempts
are horrible on their face because you
know that's immoral but on the second
layer it's counterproductive entirely to
their political cause because it's going
to spark some sympathy for the victims
yes yes absolutely yeah so I think I
think your concern
earn Joey is spot-on Thanks thank you
for taking the call all right very much
appreciated hope to hear from you again